brendan sanders wrote the stormlight
cosmere in 1972.
a lot of alternative reading orders have
popped up over the years so we're going
to have a fun
a fun time talking about brendan
fraser's storm
star cosmere if this is called the war
breaker order
you read every section of the series and
in between
you read war breaker so elantra's war
breaker miss four narrow one warbreaker
miss born arrow two warbreaker
warbreaker warbreaker stormlight archive
warbreaker white sand warbreaker arcanum
on unbounded warbreaker just a fun way
to
read the series i'm gonna get to it
i'm gonna get to it there is a final
reading order that i hesitate to discuss
[Music]
and i must express extreme
caution do not read the cosmere in this
order
unless you are prepared for the
consequences first read elantris twice
then war breaker
three times miss porn era one miss born
era two then missport
error one again the great gatsby the
lord of the rings return of the king
harry potter books seven and two war
breaker again
two times watch every brian sanders
lecture at two times speed
then read alloy of law while you are
listening to the audiobook for oathbring
again it does not give me pleasure to
reveal this information to the public i
would much prefer that i
was the only one cursed with this
knowledge brendan sanders follows me
everywhere he watches everything i do
i need help please please please i'm
sorry i'm sorry mr frazier i'm so sorry
it won't happen again
just fun little reading orders nothing
to be
worried about